nothing seems to be settled in the
aftermath of the brexit vote once again
Nigel Farage managed to provoke a fellow
mep there's a moment for everything with
his turf statement in the european
parliament regarding his decision to
stand down as you Kip leader green MP
Terry right chica has accused him of
playing with Europe's destiny I think it
just confirms his image that he is not
really taking responsibility that is a
mere populace and that he's not
interested in the interest of the
British citizens or the European
citizens but only in his own interest
and this is what he has shown with a
prime example again yesterday you keep
front leader Nigel Farage caused a
commotion here in Strasburg dropping his
chairmanship in the united kingdom while
of all things keeping his function as a
member of the European Parliament
nonetheless the European delegates now
puzzle over how to shape the you what
are the lessons learned and how to deal
with the UK's new government Richard
Corbett is a British MEP and was a
remained campaigner for him the real
solution involves solidarity he believes
the problem is not in Brussels or in
Strasbourg but in London but there's a
more fundamental reason and that is that
Britain now needs to decide what it
might seek as an alternative to EU
membership we have no settled view on
that London needs to stop beating around
the bush says the chairman of the
european conservatives house minister
this is cody it's a key facet this time
of uncertainty is that for both sides
and it's also harming the economy we
don't know what the new framework will
be like London needs to provide some
idea of how it imagines its future
relationship with the EU you don't get
to be CZ this for headedness suking
fatigue fortune ferret but europe he
says needs to draw the right conclusions
particularly on one issue zombie I think
if we can make some progress on the
refugee question and seek to tackle it
together that would be a big step
forward some shrewton in September
European leaders plan to gather in
Slovakia to coordinate further steps on
your
future and on Britain's